so yesterday it was away from Nottingham
and I missed a real exciting piece of
news the most exciting piece of the news
about the periodic table that's happened
since we've started these videos
yesterday it was announced that element
112 had finally been confirmed that it
had been observed and therefore that the
it was time for the discoverers to
choose the name for the element and I
wasn't here but three people said me
emails with the website so I knew about
it before I got back
these elements with very high numbers
are made synthetically with huge
accelerators you look at the atomic
number of the element you want to make
in this case 112 and you choose two
atoms so that they're atomic numbers
when you add them together add up to 112
so the physicists in Darmstadt where it
was discovered took lead which is number
82 and if you ant 3282 you get a hundred
and twelve so they fired atoms of zinc
zinc is element number 30 and they
accelerated these atoms of zinc to very
high speed and let them zap into a
target of lead and every so often and
very rarely two of the nuclei which are
positive charged mass at the center of
the atoms fused together so you get a
nucleus of element 112 but this is very
rare and they don't end up with a whole
beaker of a hundred 12 but they observe
these atoms by the way they decay they
give out gamma rays or other radioactive
particles so that once they made the
observation there's a big discussion
whether it was really right or not and
what happened yesterday was that the
international union of pure and applied
chemistry IU pack which decides on
whether an element has been found or not
and what it should be called came to the
decision that this really had been
discovered now you can see at the
periodic in the periodic table they have
already got element 111 which has the
almost unpronounceable name renter
Guinean which was named after rent again
the discoverer of x-rays and now they
have 112 and they can choose the name
now the element was discovered in damn
start
and they already have named an element
here number 110 dumb start him after the
place where these experiments have been
done so that name has gone they've also
used the name of Mendeleev and many of
the other famous people like Rutherford
Einstein Lorentz Lawrence and so on
so they've now got the point who is
named are they going to choose dumb
start is in Germany not far from
Frankfurt a bit further south my
grandfather worked there as a student in
the 1890s before the electron was even
discovered so very often people choose a
name that is connected with a scientist
in their country so in the context of
atoms there is still the German
physicist Heisenberg who has discovered
a principle or invented a principle do
you call the uncertainty principle
there's also Schrodinger who invented
the equation that describes the behavior
atoms in electrons in atoms Schrodinger
was an Austrian so he may not be
suitable for a German discovery then
there are really quite important people
who haven't yet been honored in the
context of the atom
there's JJ Thompson who discovered the
electron and James Chadwick who
discovered the neutron but both of those
are English so I'm not sure whether they
would do then person that I rather fancy
is the Greek Democrat and Democritus who
decided or was the first one to propose
the existence of atoms two and a half
world more than two thousand years ago
and the idea that they came up with
atoms they didn't have these complicated
machines we have nowadays they said if
you take an object like this and if you
cut it in half
and then you cut it in half again and
then you cut it in half again and so on
eventually you're going to get to a
stage where you can't cut it in half
anymore and so they decided logically
that there must be something right at
the bottom which is very very tiny which
you can't divide I think is that it
would be very nice and politically
neutral to name the elements after a
Greek philosopher many years ago which
would save all this national rivalry and
would honor people who long before they
had experiments and complicated methods
like us had already made absolutely
profound ideas about the nature of the
atoms it's the right of the inventors
and if I had to put my money on the name
I think that I would probably go for
Planck um because one of the other
people who has not been honored is Max
Planck who was one of the founders of
quantum mechanics and was German and
therefore I think that everybody in the
world would be quite happy with the
elements being called Planck him as for
the element itself 112 it's in the
periodic table in the group that begins
with zinc and ends up with Mercury
so that mercury as you know is a liquid
so this element might also be a liquid I
don't know but it's color it might well
be a more golden color because just like
caesium is more gold than rubidium or
potassium it might be in the same way
that element 112 may be a beautiful
golden liquid if we could ever make
enough why why can't we make enough what
happens
well the atoms because they're so large
so or the nucleus is so large are very
unstable
it's rather like one of these very big
soap bubbles and as you know if you've
ever blown one of these
soap bubbles it wobbles a bit and then
often breaks up into two or more small
ones and the nucleus is just the same it
breaks up very easily and the lifetime
of most of these elements is a fraction
of a second and one of the principal
interests in these making these elements
is actually to know how long they last
because there is just a suspicion that
somewhere in the really heavy elements
perhaps beyond 118 there might be an
element which is unexpectedly stable yet
it's up till now it has had a sort of
provisional name the technologies that
something has been observed and they are
you pack this in International Union has
invented a system so that you can give
any a time a name based on its number
you use an for 1 and bi B for 2 so this
is an and B but it's a dreadful name and
I haven't heard any chemists ever use
these names at all I think in the
context of chemistry element 112 is an
amusing incident but it is not really
going to change the fundamental nature
of chemistry